so first of all congratulations this is
such an exciting time with your debut
solo album out
first of all i want to talk to you about
this year so far grammy awards
an academy award and now your debut solo
album
how do you describe this year so far um
crazy
a whirlwind i don't know how else to
describe it but um
i'm so grateful it's been a blessing uh
it's been it's been hectic and so much
fun at the same time
now listen you just need an emmy and a
tony
to be for egot do you think about this
oh absolutely i definitely think about
it and it's going to happen one day
i love that do you want to get into
acting yeah actually i
i kind of had my debut in a movie called
yesterday
uh with jennifer garner and i played
myself but um the acting has been
something i've wanted to do for a really
long time but music has always come
first so
i'll be i'll definitely be in some some
tv and film very very soon
i love that okay we'll look forward to
that and it's pretty wild to me to know
that you know with
so much success you've had with your
music that only now we're getting your
debut solo album
called time i wouldn't necessarily call
it a debut with four grammys
and an oscar i don't know i don't know
if that's fair to call it anymore but
i agree album my first my first album
i mean what did you want to say with
this album what are you excited for fans
to hear
well honestly it's being my first full
body of work there's pieces of you know
my
other projects in there volume one and
volume two and i used to know her but
this is
so much of my perspective you know then
and now
up until this point um so much musically
it to me it was important to make an r b
album just because um that that's who i
am at the core and that's that's
the foundation of you know my music and
this album
it takes you through the moods of r b
it's a celebration of all the different
things that r b is whether it's
alternative
and live based or it's trap drums and
hip hop based or
or if it's just guitar if it's just you
know some of these things so
really um it's a celebration of r b
i love that you know is there kind of a
overall
theme to this this album or a message
that you want fans to know about
well you know i named my album back in
my mind just because i felt like
um all of the things that we're afraid
to face sometimes all the things we're
afraid to say are in this album
you know um i realized that i say the
things that
that sit in in the back of my mind in my
music and
and um it's really accepting that truth
and that that reality so
yeah i think that's that's really what
it is you know you've been creating
music for a while now so i'm sure you're
used to this
but do you ever fully get used to being
100
vulnerable with your music yeah it's
it's a tough thing but
uh honestly i would do it whether or not
people were listening to it it's an
outlet for me
but yeah i mean you know i'm very good
at saying everything and telling
everything and not saying anything at
all
you know that's a good trick
that's a good trick i love that um you
know you talked about how you are
a fan of bands like coldplay and
radiohead um
when it comes to zelda even though it's
a celebration of r b do you kind of pull
influences from all types of genres
oh yeah absolutely and and that's the
thing you know rb is just rhythm and
blues to me rb isn't everything
but um this album there's there's so
much of that there's songs like we made
it that are very coldplay
foo fighters drums heavy you know it's
very much about the big sounding drums
and then
um yeah there's there's a lot of my
different influences
in in this project that's awesome is it
tricky
choosing the songs you want on this
album like was that is that a hard
process
that is a very hard process and i don't
do it alone it really takes a village
but
me and and jeff my manager we always go
back and forth like
oh but this one oh but this one and
there's you know millions of songs that
i
haven't released and i might not ever
release or they might be on the next
project sometimes that happens too
so i love that is there someone in your
life that you trust 100
with to give you their honest opinion
whether it's good or bad like who's your
go-to person when you're you're showing
them your music
absolutely oh my my sister's one of them
because she's
she's 14 and she's very very honest like
and the same like she was on tour of me
and i would have a show and she'll be
like that was really good i like when
you did this and the next day she'll be
like you know
yesterday's show was better than this
one but i still liked it like she is
definitely one of those people who i'm
like
she could be honest with me 100 and
she'll always tell yeah
yeah there's no filter there that's nice
that you can have family like that with
you
absolutely it's supposed to be that way
i think yeah yeah 100
um i love that can we talk about your
love for janet jackson
oh yeah oh my gosh janet jackson is
amazing um
honestly like i can be talking about her
love for me because she came to my show
and was singing all the words to my
songs and told me that
uh i got her through her pregnancy my
music did and that it was there for her
and that's that is so surreal but she's
she's just an icon you know she's she's
a huge
inspiration lyrically and all the things
that she was you know janet was
not aren't just r b she was not just pop
like she
she did everything okay i'm sorry we
gotta rewind here so
someone that you've listened to who's an
icon for you
told you your music got her through her
pregnancy
absolutely absolutely how do you
how do you take that in i don't even
know it's just insane it's insane and
it's a blessing and it's like
confirmation like okay i'm doing
something right
janet jackson loves my music a hundred
percent what would you say
is the best piece of advice or even
words of wisdom that she's given you
that you still think about
um ah what did what did janet tell me
when i met her well she i mean she
really just told me to keep doing me
um like don't stop don't ever stop
because she loves my music but um
yeah i think i think that was the the
main thing
yeah um well i have to say i'm obsessed
with your style so is everybody else
when you walked out
uh on the oscars red carpet you made my
list of best dressed you know i love
that jumpsuit it's so
good um your glasses too they've really
become like your trademark you always
have the coolest glasses
was this on purpose or is this just your
own style and you just go with it
i mean it is my own style but honestly
in the beginning um you know they say
that the eyes are the window to the soul
but to me my music is the window to my
soul
and in the beginning when i started
doing shows i i really wanted to still
obscure myself i really wanted the focus
to be on the music and
um the lighting would be very like dim
and i thought why not wear shades you
know so people couldn't fully fully see
me
and um yeah i feel like it really it did
exactly what it was supposed to do and
now people really know that
i'm all about the music and and now it's
just a huge part of my look in my my
fashion and something i carry with me
yeah i love it um are you used to all of
this attention
like do you ever get used to this um i
don't i don't think about it i i don't
really
think about all the attention you know i
mean i think it's a blessing and
it's dope that people listen to my music
and definitely like walking down the
street
i mean it wasn't it's people don't
really recognize me unless i'm wearing
my glasses most of the time and now it's
like it's kind of unavoidable but
uh still like sometimes people are like
is that i think that is and they won't
fully say anything because they're not
100 sure but
it's like the reverse like clark kent
kind of thing you know like it really is
a mind trick like people are like i
think that's her
and then i found that and it's like oh
okay yeah that's you
that's amazing um do you feel like
you've become a role model
for people out there you have this huge
following i'm sure people tell you on a
daily basis how much your music means to
them but
i feel like you've become a bit of this
role model do you like that oh thank you
i
i love it i think it's a blessing and i
never thought that i would
have that you know um but it's it's
crazy and and
i think that is one of the goals always
to is to inspire and empower
and you know in a world where women are
are constantly put in these boxes and
constantly told that there's like a mold
of what a woman should be i feel like
i'm there to continue to break that mold
and continue to show young girls they
can be whoever they want to be and they
can do whatever they want to do so
i think it's a really really dope thing
and it's a responsibility at the same
time but
um when you walk in your passion and you
find that and it just kind of happens
you don't have to force anything
i love that um and honestly we need more
role models like you
it's just so wild to me all the success
that you've had with your music at your
age it's so
yeah inspiring for so many people um
you know when you put out this album i'm
sure there's nerves and excitement
um but critics are loving it i was just
reading reviews does that
make you feel good like do you look at
all the reviews um i don't always look
at everything um i let it simmer for a
little bit but yeah people have been
telling me
you know oh this is what so-and-so said
and this is the reaction and it's
it makes me feel great and it's like i'm
hearing my music differently now that
it's out it's like the weirdest thing
ever but i
i'm absolutely so happy and like
like people love it great okay i did
exactly what i was supposed to do and
boom that's done it's out there boom
it's finished
so when you say you're listening to
music differently like is there less
emotion attached like you're less
critical like how are you listening to
it differently
i guess i am a little less critical
because there's nothing i can do about
it now
you know and so now i'm kind of just
hearing it for what it is you know
without thinking of what i could change
or what it
like you know yeah all those little
things so it's
it's kind of cool like when people say
oh i felt this when i heard the song
it's like it kind of changed my
perspective
when i hear the song i love that well i
was looking at
birthday i know you're a cancer and you
have a birthday coming out i
do less than a week i'm 24. yeah
that's exciting i'm a cancer too cancers
unite hello um
so what what are you any plans what are
you gonna do
oh man you know i'm just gonna have a
small little gathering um but it's gonna
be it's gonna be fun it's gonna be great
and i'm actually performing at the bet
awards
um and it's on my birthday so yeah it'll
it'll be fun i'll
be on an award show stage on my birthday
that's amazing and then just drink as
much champagne as you want after to
celebrate
sure sure awesome well congratulations
on the album
all your success this year so far can't
wait to see what else you're going to do
man you are a force
oh thank you so much